hi everybody this is hand simulator
survival intro intro intro for intro
intro Thank You Tube how you doing
don't talk to my YouTube let's go on
Marcie - oh well that was quick did you
guys load it already yeah I'm here I'm
here
you know I oh boy Oh our press our wait
okay Bob look away and you ruin it you
ruin it let's see how its funnier when
I'm doing it without the voice that's
how it goes I'm gonna punch this tree
which is so much better yeah how do I
punch this tree no idea how do I look
I'm a fist it's a fist up down for punch
I've learned this from the Minecrafts
wait why isn't this working
I don't know wait I've been instructed
to do this sort of things many times in
games you punch a tree you get wood oh
good I'm very immature certain trees
that have like coconuts on them I think
coconuts
we don't need cocoa nuts well we have
hunger thirst health we need cocoa nut
so good I'm gonna I'm gonna be
struggling for a while cuz I don't even
know if this is a pickup a bull oh lawd
or believe it's pick up a book can I
kill you guys if I like wallop you and
that
Oh what you got there wait let me break
it open for you oh please do alright
here we go is that is that actually like
way you're supposed to do oh whoa what
whoa where'd my where'd I go
what where's my hand here I feel like a
rock would be more efficient but
something seems to be happening
something's have it says object -4 and I
don't know what is -4 about but a good
question I guess we'll find out if you
keep beating it with your stick
oh geez this game sucks man where'd my
end go where to go oh I dropped my stick
alright you know what screw that I hate
it let's go beat against the rock okay
cool man
Bob you're awfully quiet over there
what's going on oh you know I wondered
why you were ignoring me our fault our
fault yes yeah this is our fault I
thought I found a tree with little brown
things on it but they can't they're not
graspable I wanted to grasp
are they graspable this tiger dangerous
oh okay I see that's the same one not
different one different one not you we
left so the tiger is alone currently one
where'd you go where are you guys I
don't see you come by this
oh you're gone you're gone you guys are
gone you're gone oh you guys are
literally gone mark we're literally
where we spawn on your own goddamn
Island it's just me gotta break open a
coconut on my time what's up guys it's
your boy mark EMU here back at it again
with more survival or I need to find a
rock I found a rock got it rock
I mean voices in my head I found a rock
whatever
can you beat my nut nope beat my nut I'm
gonna eat my nut now if only there was
someone to share this bouncy glorious
you get the hell out of my way no I need
that rock there are other rocks you
idiot if you were even real figment of
my imagination
I've done it I have cracked open the
cocoa goodness I am about thrust this
into my gob
you know what mark you're yelling a lot
and I don't appreciate it this is what a
solo market blog let's plays all about
I've now no longer delusional from my
lack of well there goes my rock it never
existed in the first place
oh fish whoa I'm swimming come here fish
I forgot how to hold my breath I'm sure
there is nothing dangerous in the water
push a button
is this a scorpion is this gonna hurt me
[Applause]
are you able to resurrect me or am i
dead forever now maybe I can resurrect
you with this rock that scorpion was no
joke that scorpion tore me apart God
also don't breathe water
don't worry mark I got a rock I do not
em are you guys
never existed you vanished somewhere and
you just went away here I'm gonna I'm
gonna resurrect you with this rock ok
cool if you cut off my limbs and eat my
body so man I'm gonna grab the scorpion
I'm gonna say don't rub your face with
it
see the rock I see it please me I buy
you moved my head so my vision is
different just weekend at Bernie's
speech just like I just grab grab you by
the throat here alright this is a very
uncomfortable okay mark he kills your
enemy well thank you no oh wait oh my my
I'm lookin my neck seems to be let me
move his head around here I was up for a
second I was up for just a moment before
I slip into the great beyond I just want
to see the Scorpion but gently scoop my
hand oh my god Wade's got you here oh
God okay I see a scorpion I see it I can
see you guys my head is pointed in that
direction
that's a pretty baby yeah can we eat
that oh I dropped mark I think I dropped
him yeah of course you dropped me over
here I'm gonna feed it to you maybe this
will bring you back maybe okay thank you
your enemies will revive you that's how
this that's Oh scorpions work as far as
I know come on yeah that's great who
does your pedicures
[Music]
is it good for you no actually no all
right cool good there's this little
piece of your characters body that clips
through your underwear and I don't know
if that's gonna get my channel banned I
don't know why if I die and you guys
know this is the first step it's okay I
am going to be so I'm gonna come back as
a ghost now I'm gonna be so mad his view
is awful oh wait have you ever
resurrected anyone how do we know I have
no idea I'm gonna go out to sea I'm
gonna join mark oh you don't just like
you don't even just you just die yeah
you start yeah you just start going it's
just your health is just you get wet and
you are dead oh good yeah see all right
let's try this again with less mark
[ __ ] it all up at the beginning yeah
I don't know why I'm gonna start
collecting wood and put it in tonight
can I chop down a tree that's such a
thing how to be a way to craft right
there there wouldn't not be a way to
craft you just hold one thing in each
hand and squish them together so mark
what do we do if we come across the
scorpion oh I know this one I know it
God don't tell me yeah eat it that's
good good boy I need cuz if I if I know
my crafting you need like a rock a stick
and like something to bind it together
right I'm rockin a bone here I'm gonna
try and mush them together and see what
I get
maybe I gotta like hit things with hey
where'd you get a bone on the beach
there was a rock with a bone next to it
that doesn't sound too good no it really
is unfortunate that I have no idea what
scrap just reaching for [ __ ] at the
time not got any further than break
coconut
with rocks you guys got his force well I
assume you would know things just look
around and think there's like this weird
Viney stuff on this tree maybe this is
grabbable maybe it's but you need to
take a rock and hit stuff yeah coconut I
bet there's a rock over here I went like
left if you if you were facing inland
from where we spawned on the beach
there's another rock over here by okay
where you guys are holy schnikeys guys
technology no big tree fell on me Oh Bob
break tree where Mark were you getting
off damage like indicator like the
object at the bottom right it said 3-15
a bunch and then how am I losing you
where you said left of spawn I went you
I'm back on the little tiny tip that we
spawned on oh my god I see the rock with
balls actually Roxy you believe them
who's that this is wade go back to the
vine tree bark no I I will with rock
with rock I will yeah I need coconut
break a lot of running maybe I'm just
not left-handed that's actually more
consistent just to bang up and down on
it this isn't that bad as bad as I would
have thought yeah it's kind of like a
fresh take on survival because it's like
you have to figure out how to do
everything again and it's not just like
okay grab this grab this good thing grab
the thing yeah it's I kind of like it
it's real struggle that's like baby's
first survival if you're fresh out the
womb and end up on an island I see you
guys hey it's good tree Bob can you hit
this tree I'm not obviously I climb you
can climb it oh no
climb climb so high hello
alright okay I come down now maybe
depending on how fast be a good idea
alright I'm down anyway look boys I see
wait where's Marquette I'm buying this
just around the corner but in this point
of knows I'm near the spawn I'm right
next to you I'm literally there oh hey
this is Marc Marc come with me come is
it those beers there no sounds in this
game yeah lack sounds wait a minute this
is this is dead-ass the tree that I
chopped out I swear to god one of these
is the tree that I chopped down okay
well not this one I guess not this one
Oh strike sparks whoa this was just next
to me wait I'll drain tire oh good old
Flint and Flint good old rock and rock
firestarter oh oh well I have sticks
here wait come here I have sticks piled
up here having sticks piled up as a
generous way yeah maybe yeah really
jumping yeah yeah chicken Bob can you
don't a stick in the middle
sure there we go I did this when my hand
fire we make fire fire do it to me fire
fire fire maybe we need more wood what
happened to that tree you knocked down
whoa who hurt beat the [ __ ] out of me um
I was just experimenting and I can't
hurt you turns out hurting me does hurt
me
is this a tree wait this tree guys this
tree what which tree right here where
here is no ping it I've literally right
where we just work like right by where
we just were with the fire I went the
other way from you guys there you are
okay which tree this tree this tree
right here
it was at it and it trunk alright you
keep hitting it I'm gonna look at what I
do I see oh oh oh oh it's falling its
falling Wow fire fire fire can we break
these down though maybe oh yeah yeah you
can hit wood log fire fire fire fire
fire fire fire fire fire fire wait you
can help you can participate too is
there gonna be fire in here or no no
fire no fire okay so but we have logs
which is good yeah we got logs dude
that's that's progress baby we could
break logs down into this which is a
treat tree wood can we build something
out of this or something I'm assuming
gotta be right it's gotta be it's
getting dark guys guys am I crazy or am
I having fun no like it feels like you
shouldn't be yeah but then our an okay
I'm gonna see I'm gonna pick up one of
these if I can yes I think I got a like
scoop under it okay I got a log okay one
lies fire no fire hold fire I like how
what it's Mark's log it's not fire but
when it's my log it's fire okay are all
these your logs then do you want all the
logs down the whole tree look we share
did you just take my log yeah where's my
health dropping oh I'm freezing I'm
dying of cold yeah I really need fire we
need fire okay how we do fire
maybe if we put logs in like the shape
of a fire maybe it's just like a fire is
hard to make we just got a spark a lot
maybe it's one person all no we were
making sparks but maybe it'd be more
efficient if one person holds rock in
each hand here Bob you yeah you get the
rocks I'm gonna pile up the wood hurry
Bob is so cold I got this don't worry
yes oh oh I just got a coffee donut
delivery making lots of sparks not
getting not
getting many fires oh you keep out that
I'm gonna grab one sliver of health left
so I'll see you guys in the next one a
Baba good night sweet prince
what is that you put that over here I've
got like a little spot here where I can
okay let me grab the other stick I I got
a little elf I'm sorry if I died on the
wood but I'm dead you're good more fire
he'll burn yeah
should we have tried to light plants on
fire liar liar pants on fire yeah cause
he's gotta be I'm abandoning the wood
it's fine out of the gun of time it's
just terrible
I think there's like a lighthouse or a
boat or something maybe that's it maybe
there's boats that go by and you got a
signal to the boat to come get you
I'm gonna just be bringing things back
to where we spawn sticks cocoanuts rocks
I'm just gonna go out and get them okay
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go up this way
the beach I'll just be bringing back
whatever I can okay I want to go the ops
away from you mark okay sounds good wait
what if there's a certain number of
things that you need to do something
what if we didn't have enough wood in
the pile I mean there was a lot of wood
I think maybe sticks I think if we had
more sticks it might have worked I want
to try wait I want to try and use like
every piece of wood that you when we
break down the logs I want to use like
like a round number like five or ten or
something I just feel like if we're if
we're a bit we're basing this off of
like normal survival game stuff right
like that's that's how it work there's
like a set there's like a recipe yeah
there's got to be a recipe for
everything but I'm thinking it sticks
less than the logs logs must be for like
building things what I come back and
wage dis rubbing the log with his gave
us so silly in the best way yeah I don't
have no idea I didn't expect to enjoy I
thought of it and it would be over with
that's what Wade was building it up for
we didn't play it much because we kept
fighting the wildlife and dying very
fast well then
there's your proof there's also snakes I
will warn you okay I've got two rocks
one stick one coconut I'm gonna go four
sticks now I'm gonna try a bigger pile
of logs
that's I'm gonna try a bigger pile of
sticks try to figure pilot your mom your
law there's there's five logs yeah why
can't I pick up logs there we go here
logs you don't know when this bursts
into flame at at my very first try
you're gonna feel like such a dumb-dumb
when I burst into flames on my third try
you're gonna feel like a dumb-dumb
possibly maybe we need a combination of
sticks and logs maybe you need a
combination of shut up
okay wait get your extra log out of here
you're ruining my thesis Oh
five logs why are you doing this my logs
get this log out of here get this log
out of here any more sticks bother six
logs there get the sixth one off of here
what are you doing to me oh no that is
the right number okay Wow there's one
that's like half in the crowd I don't
know if that counts or not yeah stick
guys bring it to us
unga-bunga i found big stick it big why
no women on this island you know what
mark what's up you might be right about
the sticks okay yeah can we pool our
collective knowledge I got a pile of
sticks working there you'll see it all
this is enough this is so enough right
now guys you ready for this
wait do you know something that we don't
know why would I know something that you
don't know you seem pretty confident
I wish I was there for that holy [ __ ]
okay all right
oh my god I was standing on top of it in
a way from nothing to this wait wait are
you really would I'll find you guys wait
I think I know why you didn't have
success before what do you mean no it's
fine it's gonna [ __ ] be okay I burned
this did you guys go left or right from
the Frog the hell are you talking about
what did you is that working that thing
mark did I add to the fire I wasn't
looking I'm coconut Oh dinner didn't it
dude the beach yeah come to the fire oh
god you're so far away Wade what have
you been doing I took a wrong turn at
the Frog okay reference the Frog like we
know what that is though there's a frog
and I reference okay well as a frog so
can we cook a scorpion or something can
we cook a coconut we must be able to
write is it is it more nutritionally
nutritionally beneficial if we roast a
coconut good idea I'll grab the Frog
there's no frog I guarantee that Bob
there's no frog he's gone no frog he's
getting he's getting beach madness yeah
the science is very clear when it comes
to beach madness there's only one
solution and it's it's pretty gruesome
but Bob I think you're up to the task
you know what I mean I will do this
family you're the strong one among us
all right we got coconut wait have you
brought even a single thing back to the
camp three marks he did cut down the
tree that's that's accurate thing with
with cuisine here boys hang on I swear
the Frog was real
I almost had it but the Frog turned into
a tiger queen I'm actually worried by
your adore there yeah I gotta believe
the Frog turned into a tiger yeah okay I
do you alright snake snakes a problem
obviously comeback guys oh that's scary
be gonna bring anything back with you
you're gonna bring something back we're
just gonna run a rock great job buddy
guys I was gonna bring the Frog to cook
but stuff happened uh-huh uh-huh I was I
believe you we'd you don't need to keep
justifying hi Bob how are you good I got
supplies bringing it back to camp it's
cool man in this pool probably like my
eighth trip back oh I found mushrooms
can I can I eat you mister mushrooms it
did Wayde find mushrooms a little
earlier than you it's getting cold guys
come to the fire
move guys I'm coming back with
absolutely nothing oh my god are you
serious nothing no I was trying to hunt
with the hunt one today
when was hunter property for us can I
take a burning stick into the woods who
torch that's called a torch I know this
one
torch very hot maybe you should get an
on burning one in your hand and then
stick it in their inventory or anything
or probably have to make a backpack
right or something like oh god sakes
hey it's warm here yeah okay whoa I drop
as soon as fire oh oh the coconut takes
your thirst from zero all the way up
that's nice they're filled with juices
yeah real good
yeah dude we're in California we know
coconut water my god well so there was a
roasting coconut coconut half on the
ground a Friday my edible no I ate that
I don't know if it was any better but it
helped it oh it didn't get my thirst up
all the way that is the thing Oh
interesting
I think that did change it so I'm
yeah maybe which is probably a good
thing I'm gonna go get more coconuts
yeah into a string ocean water right I
mean yeah that yeah wait how's that hunt
going
did you get the stuff we were trying to
get Wade the frog the frog won the Frog
won was it a condo just turned into a
tiger and then there was a snake it's
not really my fault
if you think about it like if that's all
real that sounds horrifying you're lucky
to be alive Oh what does that mean well
I don't like that are bringing two
coconuts back all right coming home
coming home boys I know you missed me I
miss you daddy
apparently weird okay weird cool good
oh my temperature gauge yes it's bad is
the problem about nine times
oh no the fires going down do we have
more sticks well the sun's coming up so
what I think we're okay freakin sound
who's ANCA near it's coming from where
the Sun rises all right that's just the
sound the Sun makes in this year nothing
sticks there is nothing on that half the
island let me tell you it's a desolate
wasteland not worth your time the other
way wait found a tree I found a tiny
little tree I think I can make it into
sticks yeah yeah come here come here
come here
which ways here all right bring a rocker
are you okay I got the rock situation I
just cut down one here I'll just bring
it morning to just night again yeah sure
did women we might die if we don't kid
sticks where are you at Bob I went I
went the way that you had went to the
okay to the right from our spawn looking
in the island to the right correct yeah
well death is a real close
why is death real close yeah why have no
temperature well but I didn't get to
heat it up at all why not what because I
got back late
so you didn't stay near the fire I was
the fire but didn't go up enough to
matter did it work I cut down a tree
here somewhere here there's a tree but I
can't [ __ ] see it if we start a fire
we can locate it snake attack there's a
snake here oh crap
so little little tree little tree I made
into indistict
interesting interesting interesting
interesting there's another little tree
here let me see if this was that light
we saw oh for God's sake I just got
attacked by a snake yeah this I found
another little tree
I'm dead now please wait
good so the answer is to cut down these
little trees and bring those back the
next time cuz then we can break them
into sticks right there we need lots of
sticks we need a nice worth of sticks
I'm gonna come back and walk slowly into
the ocean Wade you find that frog okay
that's on the log in the bog it's past
the fog go on you got this mark it was
real yeah yeah yeah I know I believe you
the thing is Abel was real I believe you
before I do that I'm just gonna see how
many sticks this tree will break and do
oh wait no it doesn't break into sticks
this is like bamboo spear maybe maybe
this torch walk slowly in the ocean I
walk fast
Oh God scary at night guys we got this
guys we've got this I can't believe it's
fun but we got this Wade tell me what is
your plan in this next game all right
I'm gonna start off by getting the rock
uh-huh okay I'm gonna break down a tree
for the logs then I'm gonna look for the
bamboo tree it's some bamboo I'm gonna
try to make a spear with that spear I'm
gonna try to hunt a tiger all right
that's a plan all right let's go rock
our objective 1 complete found the rock
nice bamboo tree look like bamboo okay I
mean it just looks good trees here look
like wood trees but you know they don't
necessarily all give you wood so well
you didn't look at the one that did it
looked very distinctly different
I know but they although all look like I
didn't know if the bamboo tree look
different I've got haha looks like
bamboo - alright I got a bone or wood
this big weird so wait what is that is
it the sound of me running no I hear
you're talking about I'm moving toward
it what is yes definitely move toward
the weird sound that's what we need
also I think we only need to light the
fire once night falls
that's probably probably a thing it's up
on top of this rock thing don't worry
I'm going up to investigate this can
only end well okay so you can't hit the
bamboo with rock so it is just bamboo
okay I don't think I can get high enough
to investigate this okay I really need
to figure out how to make little sticks
that's what we need yes little sticks I
mean there are plenty of sticks in the
brush like there's lots we're not
supposed to make them we're just
supposed to find whatever's happened to
wait
I love that Oh guys I found a beehive
that looks obviously like a beehive that
I saw and was like maybe I shouldn't
touch that oh my god I didn't touch it I
just saw it okay the bits that you make
when you're off on your own wait I just
don't know what's happening I'm an
investigative journalist no nope that's
wrong you're not I'm just gonna find
things that I could hit with I'm the guy
who's not telling you what you can and
cannot be are you an investigative
journalist which all no tell them good
talk
there's a tiger what's the aggro range
on the tiger I'm about to pretty close
he'll turn and look at you okay but you
don't want mess he knows what's up right
am i right my bros probably yeah
I'm gonna bring a log back for all the
good a log does us I still feel like
these bad boys should be walkable with
the with the rock but they're not I feel
like so much should be walkable if I
could go through life I'm dying you dead
no barely seems better heal
alright knew I knew it was their thing
you guys you guys keep working hard all
right so no change everyone doing same
stuff okay I find a bone oh yeah i'ma
sharpen it make a bone knife actually
that I wonder if that would I would
probably work my work
see ya know that's bone it better watch
out
whew almost stepped on a squirt
I'm gonna try to kill it yeah we got
bamboo with the camp that's neat
yeah I still haven't seen the bamboo
tree it's a lot like bamboo yeah it's
what you guys keep saying I just haven't
seen one I guess or else I haven't
realized I've seen one Oh
just dies did you squish him I squished
him good can I eat him is it good to eat
or is it gonna poison me not can't eat
it must be able to cook him though I
want a fight what if I sharpen this bone
by rubbing it with my rock that's
working that's getting it is it any dead
no it's not doing anything
all right that's unfair all right guide
me back to camp no Chad don't do it
could use a little guidance to get back
to my friend OHS they need me friends I
see one of you how big is this island by
the bus oh how the Frick are you here
where'd you go uh that way how are you
eating how no answer me how are you here
I don't know where here is but you know
I was over there now I'm here what do
you mean over there I went the complete
opposite direction on the island you did
you just run around the entire island no
no I climbed up with some rocks and I
ended up over there and now I'm here
okay keep walking that way you'll get
back that's good oh my god Bob I don't
know if you need to see this explain why
because it's a living thing go to the
middle of the island no I'm running
around the outskirts and that's Reverend
away it's not very pretty far I'm pretty
far if you look inward from the island
from spawn I'm pretty far right I don't
know I'll tell you if this is worth
looking at wait whatever I'll accept
your judgment what do we it's real I
swear to you it's real hey is that the
Frog is it the Frog wow this was so
worth it
I just needed you to know I wasn't crazy
before I did this come here can I like
that why would you do that I'm just
gonna careful it turns into a tie here
killed it
alright cool well we got food that's for
sure Bob there was a frog I will bring
it back and show it to you oh snap I
told you I'm not crazy
I don't tear this frog limb from limb
and eat it till there's nothing left
with bones wait be careful well the
snake yeah
well also they're friendly if you don't
let him eat you see look he's fine wait
are you not leavin looking all that
that's fine that used to be a frog
please literally went the direction I
thought would take me the farthest rib
waited somehow we're walking together
why are we walking together good work
with you frog each one of those words
was more outrageous than the
oh hi Bob all right hi
fantastic I've got a bone in a stick
nice all right we got to light that fire
soon what I don't know if we have enough
for fire I I got a bunch of sticks back
home
look I've been putting the hours in I've
been doing my work
I've been trying I'm not good at finding
sticks stative journalists that's not
true
bottle playing pretend well this is
survival Wade this is life weren't
coming back with another Rock in a
coconut we have play of rocks wait do we
have plenty of coconuts no the answer
might surprise you all right you already
answered never mind um temperature is a
problem already didn't it I'm going like
that fire baby like that fire wait where
am I tonight overshoot you guys wait
what the hell
I made the fire that's it's bad it's
fire time where am I
what how did I get lost where am I what
Wow
what no no no where am I anyway doing I
mean I was freezing to death how are you
mark you just gotta come to where we are
guys I literally have no idea where I
ended up ah there how the hell did I get
that far wet look at where I am oh wow
where'd you go
dude all right uh I passed you I went
two inches and then I somehow ended up
on the other side of the island
look I'm normally I'm cold dude I I'm
okay for now I'll be fine if I get back
okay well maybe not my stamina is real
low I don't have a lot of thirst
am I gonna die of thirst if I don't get
can you want what do you guys crack a
coconut for me when I get back I don't
think I can run back my thirst is gonna
go too low
guys I'm I need help if one of you could
bring a coconut to me like this is I'm
not joking
I do not know how the hell I got here
need some sustenance a something don't
send Wade anybody but Wade right it's
coming don't why not bring Wade
Wade's the opposite of what I need my
thirst illegitimate
my thirst is one sliver away I do not
know if I got I gotta go dude wait what
the friggin late notice here mark oh how
does it take you to break up with a
coconut that entire time he was breaking
open a coconut oh my god
okay well health is now down to one
sliver temperatures starting to go back
up I need it put it in there in my hand
okay got it
okay bring it up okay eat this from my
hand okay thank you eat I don't even
need to hold it you right that's good
okay thank you thank you
how does it feel to be in my debt I said
thank you
about the fact that you depended on me
to save your life look just because the
Island Airport it teleported me to some
far-off dimension does not mean that I
owe you my life
your life was in my hands Oh Bob but
also I came through to Bob Bob I think
Bob I think Bob I think Bob Bob don't be
so modest oh wait a very large debt of
gratitude
oh no no Bob don't be humble don't be
humble
it doesn't look come on guys oh it's
gone no sir I see it's a little little
sliver on the horizon what do we have
you tried putting a bamboo in the fire
yet oh no let me try that
I've got there's meat in the fire I
don't know if it's doing anything here
burn is it lit what's it doing all right
well this isn't doing we're gonna need
more sticks hey Mark you know some beef
you want some frog beef I would love
some frog beef a little closer yeah
apparently it's not letting me eat it
oops oh I got it that's a weird-looking
frog man yeah one naughty little frog
broke into two pieces of meat that size
wow that's pretty crazy
it seems to be a little raw I'm gonna
well just gonna all right but we'll get
you tomorrow night how close to the fire
does this need to be to cook I don't
know I had it sitting in the fire and it
wasn't cooking so I'm not 100% sure how
that works sure this is meat it was
called meat I guess it was once frog oh
my god oh my god Bob watch out watch out
Bob Bob
wait did it just go in the fire what the
hell is so bad I lost my rock somebody
help me try to kill this one oh it's
disappeared oh wait over by where I saw
a snake what happened whoa there's a
snake over here oh god I'm gonna die
from this scorpion I am going to do oh
that's okay so lesson learned lesson
learned right island madness is not
something to be trifled with the snake
is still attacking me the snake is
moving my dead body I don't want you
that yeah that is I'm gonna try to kill
this snake please um oh god that was
scary so that was weird
that's what we get for killing the Frog
oh you might be right mother nature you
scary well guys we were doing at that
time where we held that now we yeah we
mark I saved your life remember he did
save your life
I do not recall you save your life I was
good to have mark in a life debt life
life dead life dead all right what
happens in handsome survival happens in
real life you guys want to move on to
some house one where I don't know we
don't let you know if you don't want to
deal with being in my life debt anymore
right now you know I'll remember I'll
definitely remember like favorite
subscribe
and about the life that on every mark of
life fit him just make sure he never
forgets
[Music]